c'est une petite histoire au coeur de la
grande
maureen airways est américaine elle
découvre la chapelle royale du château
de versailles
c'est ici qu'un mariage a marqué son
histoire familiale
la mariée était la petite soeur de mon
père le marié était l'homme dont elle
est tombée amoureuse en afrique du nord
il est l ordonnance personnel du général
eisenhower et elle son chauffeur nous
connaissions cette histoire parce qu'il
a écrit un livre intitulé sérgio micky
et general electric
le 16 décembre 1944 michael matthews et
par les argos 10 oui en présence du
général eisenhower une célébration
inscrits dans les archives du château
ce mariage est tout à fait exceptionnel
en fait il est probablement le seul et
l'unique après le mariage de du futur
louis saez et de marie antoinette en
1770 donc c'était vraiment un événement
exceptionnel est qui et qui se légitime
par le fait que les américains étaient
positionnés au trianon palace et donc
libérez évidemment la france l europe et
les jeunes mariés ont ensuite passé leur
lune de miel à paris maureen arbres il
continue ses recherches
sa prochaine étape amsterdam